I don't understand it's October top five
and Ayana is still nowhere to be found
I'm sure she's fine Walter it's x-files
week she wouldn't miss this are you
what's her noise oh my god did you even
check this room see she's fine oh my god
you guys we don't meet again hey buddy
how do I went searching for answers but
all I found were more questions but I've
done it we've done it Scully and Mulder
these are the top 5 best x-files
episodes x-files is a science-fiction
drama series that aired 11 seasons
between 1993 and 2018 Fox Mulder a
conspiracy believer and Dana Scully the
level-headed doctor are FBI agents and
partners assigned to investigate the
more supernatural cases that can't be
solved by other means
what started as a cult following has now
been widely accepted as one of the best
American television series and sci-fi
pop-culture phenomenon number 5 memento
mori
cancer can be a very difficult topic for
a show to tackle but here the x-files
does it well the premise of memento mori
is pretty straightforward Scully is
diagnosed with a rare form of cancer
Mulder and Scully find that it is
related to a case they previously
investigated with a group of women who
claim to be abducted all the women in
that group have died of the same cancer
Scully now has all except one the pair
travels to Pennsylvania to meet penny
the sole survivor and see what answers
they can find about Scully's illness in
the process we see that Scully was also
abducted memories come back to her in
pieces as she struggles to make sense of
what happened to her and the cause of
her sickness she eventually checks into
the hospital in Pennsylvania because
there is a doctor there that possibly
has a cure the two women form a
beautiful friendship forged in their
shared traumas and disease
the episode really does a great job with
handling the material we get to see
Scully struggle with her diagnosis and
try to deal with it in the best way
possible we see how it affects the
people in her life that she cares about
ultimately Scully has a wonderful moment
at the end of the episode where she
decides with determination that she is
going to fight this no matter what
I decided tonight that
then I'm not gonna let this thing beat
me there's also some great pacing
comedic and supernatural relief are
provided at the right times throughout
so it doesn't feel like a struggle to
get through in true x-files fashion
molder does discover an alien and
government conspiracy with clones that
is behind the whole situation overall it
has some hard-hitting emotional moments
mixed with an interesting supernatural
plot number four squeeze this is one of
the earliest episodes in the series
episode 3 to be exact and it really
helped hook audiences into the show in
squeeze Scully is contacted by an old
friend agent Colton he presents to her a
case that he is working on that has some
strange circumstances namely that people
are being murdered by having their
livers ripped out of their bodies with
someone's bare hands he figures since
gully is now working with the infamous
spooky Mulder and the x-files division
she and Mulder might have some theories
as to what is going on they start
investigating and Mulder soon discovers
that this is a series of murders that
happens every 30 years Mulder and Scully
find that the culprit is a man who has
mutated so that he must consume some
livers for nutrients before hibernating
and a self-made den of paper and bile
for 30 years to wake up and do the whole
process again he can also bend and
stretch his body to fit into small
spaces like air ducts the best part of
this episode though is the exploration
and growth of the relationship between
Mulder and Scully as well as other
agents in the FBI we get one of our
first glances into how Scully's
classmates view her in her new position
it's considered a joke that creates
moments of tension where Scully is
forced to choose between backing Colton
or placing her trust in Mulder look Tina
whose side are you on the victims the
episode also begins to establish and
grow the relationship between Mulder and
Scully Scully is skeptical but also
willing to listen to Mulder Mulder is
confident in his theories and pursues
them despite people's doubts and
taunting there's really a conscious
effort on Scully's part to start to
trust her partner despite how others see
him it truly highlights the beginning of
an iconic partnership our investigations
you may not always agree with me
or at least you respect the journey
number 3 postmodern Prometheus what's
black and white and walking in Memphis
with blue suede shoes like I mentioned
in this episode is in black and white
and the dramatic towns folk are weird
enough for a Jerry Springer Show in fact
some of them have been on the Jerry
Springer Show
after being mysteriously impregnated
while unconscious in a circus a
fumigation tent and left with foggy
memories of Cher songs one woman
experiences a second immaculate
conception and Scully and Mulder
investigate only to find out this woman
had a tubal ligation and is therefore
infertile her first son writes a comic
about the great Mutato a disfigured
individual who is more than just a
small-town legend and seems worth
question Scully and Mulder also
interview a local gene mapping scientist
who wields his godlike power with
reckless abandon why would you do that
because I can the practical effects have
aged really well and as its frankenstein
roots suggest so as the story this
standalone episode is campy and fun
while still not shying away from
exploring people's prejudices and mob
mentality the share references
throughout our simultaneously hilarious
and amazingly touching almost as
important as its seven Emmy nominations
it has the achievement of arguably the
best ending to an x-files episode number
two home this episode is not for the
weak of heart or stomach seriously it
opens with burying a child's remains in
a thunderstorm after a tragic car
accident a decade ago the mother and
father of the peacock family are
presumed dead
the remaining peacock sons live in a
rundown home without modern amenities
farming and butchering their own food
this reclusive family is rumored to be
incestuous and violent are the locals
fears valid this episode has a lot of
grotesque imagery so if you're upset by
that or want to keep away from spoilers
skip ahead now seriously spoilers and
gore ahead when a newborn's corpse is
discovered next to the Peacocks
residence Scully and Mulder are called
to investigate the infanticide as Scully
and moulders investigations progress
they
year the Peacocks have kidnapped and
raped a woman burying the unwanted
offspring unfortunately they're prying
was being watched by someone hidden in
the home to make matters worse the
peacock sons and this hidden voice vowed
to keep their existence safe from
outsiders and meddling townsfolk which
in their mind means nixing the sheriff
and his wife who refused to investigate
them in the first place this episode
features some of the most bone-chilling
loyalty with convoluted rationalizing
even the booby traps set by the peacocks
are morbidly childish this was followed
by the horrifying reveal that the
reclusive spy was the peacocks matriarch
the mother's willing participation and
active fighting to return under the bed
has stuck with me since this episode
first aired this story isn't connected
to the show's arc so if you want an
unsettling thrill I recommend giving it
of you just don't say I didn't warn you
[Applause]
[Music]
and the number one best episode of
x-files is Clyde Brockman's final repose
this episode features a serial killer
with a fascination for fortune tellers
and psychics practitioners he asks a
palm reader why he will be doing the
horrible atrocities he will be
committing before he murders her what's
his excuse oh that she should have seen
it coming
when Scully and Mulder joined the case
they meet Clyde bruckman an insurance
salesman who knows details about their
cases not released to the public while
this should make him the perfect suspect
we discover Clyde happens to have the
ability to predict everyone's death
unfortunately for him and his lottery
habit his powers don't reach further
than that this also doesn't help Scully
and moulders investigation as accurately
as they would like but they still get
some secret insights nonetheless as the
story unfolds we are led to the
conclusion that the killer also has some
sort of precognition and wrestles with
the concept of free will if his crimes
are already foretold molders eagerness
to believe sets him up to be the center
of one of the killer's predictions and
while Scully maintains her trademark
skepticism Clyde is still able to make a
meaningful impression on her the
coincidence is throughout this episode
are really fun and handled in
interesting ways there's also a good
balance between sincere emotion and
humor ultimately this episode won Emmys
for outstanding writing in a Drama
Series and outstanding Guest Actor in a
Drama Series for Peter Boyles memorable
performance we want to hear what you
guys think what's your favorite x-files
episode what do you want to see us cover
next on the show leave a comment and let
us know to keep in touch you could like
my Facebook page or follow along on
Twitter and you can find me on Facebook
Twitter Instagram or subscribe to my
animated move your review series right
here on YouTube and you can find me on
Twitter Instagram or Twitter I stream on
Wednesday nights we'll catch you right
back here next week on a brand new
episode of October top 5 where we
countdown the worst x-files episodes
wait the worst uh I've got more research
to do come on Walter to the dressing
room
I'm not helping your bill to keep the
conspiracy wolf yeah no she took the
dummy with her guess you're off the hook
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]